trainee edit are lame is the feature
film the park vitals quite not really
unusual but I knew for sure when i
finished my a-levels i wanted to go to
university but i had no idea what I
wanted to do so but I did like something
in a media industry so that's my first
episode so I did a mediator green I
whilst on the media degree it was so
called I was able to do a bit of
journalism looking to that may be a bit
of TV and we covered film and filming
and then I've found that I'll hold on me
I quite like film and in once I
graduated I am kind of researched about
different sort placement schemes things
are available free because I couldn't
afford to do a masters or go to film
school and a first light which is that
absolutely amazing sort of company they
help young people who inspire resort
filmmakers they were doing a pilot
scheme on one off for years to take on
ten young people between ages at 18 and
24 to have to gain hands-on film
training
and I got on the papal scheme for a year
I create we made 11 short films and
that's thought of my career I kind of
was able to experiment learn about more
the film industry no old it and then I
quite like editing any learn I knew how
important it was to gain work experience
which is some number one thing you have
to get experience so I've got work as
I'm run out frame store which was a
visual effects Coast facility housed in
soho and got worked there as a runner
and someone just took his shining
scientist shown to me and I've got off
of the job on future film gravity last
year and in since then I applied for
school set training and skills that
fakes patient scheme called craft and
tech skills academy
and I got on that placement scheme and
now i'm working on main mr. Larkin loves
doing something if you want to become an
editor you have to get software
otherwise how else you're going to learn
on how else are you going to help your
friends who do music videos and stuff
like that you know so I've actually got
software homo Cup Final Cut Pro and I
want to get abid so i can do training at
home but there are a lot of online free
web tutorials and in my spare time at
home i do go online and i do these web
tutorials and stuff of that a typical
day for a runner whoa wow it varies a
lot some days you might not have to do a
bath amount so you use your time wisely
I say that you go in your sneak into
different suite you see what editors are
doing I've been fortunate that audiences
I've worked more being really nice and
don't mind me sort of looking over their
shoulder but that's just that's very
unusual parently and then so typically a
day you might just be shadowing and if
they are 20 you go and grab something
maybe a cup of tea or their lunch and
stuff of that that's what you may do but
a lot of it you are running around and
chasing up on paperwork you're doing a
lot of sort of filing put some on the
craft and tech training ship plating
skills
and this is my first working on lately
is my first trainee Phil and training
position and then I've got another
placement do with them because you get
to places in the year so after this I'll
get hopefully they'll find me another
jobs go onto so as a training after end
of the next one hopefully I would have
got enough experience to then apply to
become an assistant episode so that is
my next step